Thanks for,
thanks for everybody coming out.
It's great to see so many of your
hair. Uh, I'm just, I'm smart.
I'm a engineer on the Google assistant
team and I'm just going to introduce the
Dan and Rosie who are thrilled
to have with us today. Um,
I'm curious how many of you guys got
to see this piece while it was, uh,
by the subway cars in
outside five VB? Yeah. Cool.
For those of you who haven't, I really
encourage you to stick around afterwards,
get right up close to it and you'll see
all these incredible surprising details
that the AI is imbued into this piece.
And you'll hear all about that from Dan.
Uh, my connection to it is just that, uh,
we used to know each other from a previous
company that I was in and when Dan
started working on this
computational photography stuff,
he saw deep dream is an opportunity to
work it in and kind of an artistic way
and asked if I could help him.
And I didn't really know anything
about the software and I thought, okay,
you know,
how hard could this be?
And of course these things always turn
out to be a lot more complicated than you
thought. I'll go into a
little bit of that afterwards.
But what was really fascinating to me is,
you know,
this all kind of started because of
New York City and that's why it's so
exciting to have it here.
About 50 years ago today,
almost right there was maybe 51 by now.
There was one of the very first art plus
technology shows in New York City ever
called nine evenings.
And about 50 years later,
a bunch of the people decided it would
be really cool to do a retrospective and
kind of a new show.
And they decided to do it out in Seattle.
And Dan was one of the artists that were
commissioned to build a piece for nine
evenings too. And so he shot it in New
York City. This is for those of you,
it's not obvious, it's the Azalea
walk inside of Central Park.
And so it sort of coming from
New York with New York content,
but of course with a much more modern
twist and after it finished touring a few
places in Seattle, he thought, wouldn't
it be cool to bring it back to Manhattan?
And Google was excited to be able to
take it and put it in the building.
So it's kind of neat to kind of bring it
full circle. And while Dan was in town,
I thought it would be great for him to
talk through because it's not just sort
of release for me.
It's really cool to hear about the neat
photography tricks and the computer
tricks that was necessary.
But there's also a whole sort of art
history that Dan has of how people over
time figured out how to paint these
compelling landscapes and compositional
elements.
That was really new to me.
So I hope that'll be
interesting to you guys as well.
And afterwards we've got some refreshments
and stick around for the reception.
You get a chance to talk
to Dan Moore and uh,
we'll leave plenty of time for Q and.
A. So with that I'll turn it over.
Thanks a lot.
[inaudible]
thanks Joseph, and thanks to
you all for being here. Um,
my plan here is to take you
through the art history,
the technology and the psychology
even behind our dreamscapes project.
I hope you're going to find this fun and
perhaps learn some new things along the
way. Just a heads up that, um, all
of the images in this presentation,
unless otherwise noted,
are my own work.
So let's talk about special places.
What I mean by that are precise locations
in our world where something very
powerful happens.
And I'm not just talking about landscapes,
but also city scapes
and even indoor spaces.
I mean, have you ever noticed that
in certain places at certain times,
the scene before you goes beyond a mere
sight and become something you feel in
your body?
Does anyone ever had that experience
hiking or skiing or something like that?
Whenever I find myself in the midst of
scenes like that, it's like a bell rings.
It just stops me dead in my tracks.
Um,
what starts then as a visual experience
immediately becomes a visceral response.
One that I feel right in the middle of
my chest usually because it makes me gasp
and when I've seen is powerful
enough to make that happen.
I found myself waxing philosophical,
asking questions like,
I wonder how a butterfly would see this,
you know?
Or what if my vision was many times
sharper? What's real? Anyway, you know,
Physics explains and tells us how we see
the world through very limited filter,
so I'm sure many of you have
experienced something like this too,
in the presence of special places,
this powerful connection that's
quickly formed between your eyes,
your body and your mind,
and if you're like me and many other
people in the history of mankind,
I suspect you then find
yourself desperately wanting
to bottle that experience
with such fidelity that when
you share it with others later,
the same thing happens to them.
Right?
Also like me,
you may have found it very hard to
do that with traditional photography.
This drove me crazy.
It had me wondering what constitutes
this phenomenon and how can it be
communicated? Is it even
possible? The answer is yes.
Let me show you how it turns out.
We have an existence proof the great
American painters of the Hudson River
school in the early 18 hundreds and the
European romanticist before them achieve
this effect.
They painted highly detailed scenes,
some of which were 10 feet wider,
more with great emotional impact.
Painters like Thomas Cole,
who's considered the founder of the
Hudson River school and is incredibly
skilled friend Asher,
B Duran and several others created
many powerful works like these
coals.
Protege Frederick Edmund Church was
hugely successful at doing this.
Let's talk about this painting for a
minute is called the heart of the Andes.
When this five and a half foot high by
10 foot wide masterpiece debuted in 1859
it was an absolute sensation.
It was first exhibited in New York
City as a single painting exhibition.
In four weeks. More than 12,000 people
paid admission to view this painting.
It was set up in this interesting little
stage with a skylight putting light on
it in a darkened room.
They had benches set up,
they handed people opera glasses.
People were crazy about this thing.
Um,
the painting was widely acclaimed.
Poetry was written in its honor.
A composer dedicated a piece to it.
Mark Twain wrote about it.
The following quote proves my point that
it is indeed possible to capture and
convey the power of a special place.
A contemporary witness wrote this,
women felt faint.
Both men and women succumb to the dizzy
and combination of terror and vertigo
that they recognized as the sublime.
Many of them will later describe as
sensation of becoming immersed in or
absorbed by this painting
who's dimensions, presentation
and subject matters.
Speak of the divine power of nature.
So by the way,
this painting hangs up town at the met.
Now, if you haven't already done done so,
you should really see it in person.
Joseph just sought for the first time
on Sunday. What did you think? Amazing.
Um, before I get into exactly how Frederic
Church and his contemporaries did what
they did, I want to mention one more
panel who was very influential to me.
Maxfield Parrish Parrish came
along much later, in fact,
well after the art world had moved on
from representational landscape painting,
but he brought a level of vibrancy and
lucidity to his work that I absolutely
love and which really
hadn't been seen before.
I don't have time to explain
how he did what he did,
but one thing I can relate to is that
he did it by tinkering and experimenting
with both old and new
approaches to his medium.
Okay.
Okay. Now let's get into the how. I'll
use my own work to illustrate this.
Starting with this scene that I
captured at Nymph Lake in Rocky Mountain
National Park, Colorado
in healthcare design,
there's been a lot of research around
what is known as healing art designers and
administrators wanted to know.
Yeah.
What kind of art, if any, can
reliably make patients feel better?
Well, it turns out there
is only one kind that does,
and that's representational
landscape scenes.
Healthcare design consultant Barbara
Lyons Stewart wrote every evidence based
design study I found has proven that
only viewing representational landscape
scenes measurably decreases heart rate,
blood pressure and pain
while improving mood.
Some people refer to this effect
as the pastoral experience,
but when you dig into this,
you find out the pastoral experience is
not achieved by subject matter alone.
It actually requires four things.
Subject matter, composition,
technique and presentation. Let's
briefly considered these one at a time.
Starting with subject matter.
The pastoral experience occurs with
scenes featuring things like greenfields.
It also includes water scenes,
Heelan, country scenes,
sweeping views,
coastal views,
Marsha's
farm land,
groves of trees,
beautiful Vestas,
sunrises and sunsets.
But like I said,
it's not just about subject matter.
It's also about composition and
a guide to evidence based art.
The author specifically mentioned
immersion compatibility and extent
immersion is best achieved with the
presence of strong foreground elements and
or wide fields of view.
Compatibility refers to the resonance
between the natural setting and human
inclinations.
Essentially,
manmade elements subconsciously
make the viewer feel safe.
They sense that other
people are thriving there
and then there's extent
which is characterized by
scenes of distant wilderness
trails and paths leading to
idyllic destinations and a
sense of being connected
to a larger world.
This quote really sums it up.
The most fundamental feature
of a restorative place is
that people have to feel
that they can move into those spaces
and have a wonderful experience.
Okay.
Now let's talk about technique.
How do we achieve the pastoral
effect with a digital camera?
With the digital cameras?
It'll start with, it starts
with something I call x, Y,
Z photography. You'll see why I call
it that in just a minute. First,
let me tell you about the gear.
The Sony Rx one was the first full
frame sensor compact camera when it was
released a bit more than four years ago.
It's got everything I need and nothing
more and incredibly small foreign factor,
a beautiful fix,
35 millimeter Carl Zeiss Lens,
and the new version has a
whopping 42.4 megapixel sensor
with a small camera like this one,
I can get away with a fairly compact
tripod on top of which is a similarly
compact but very important contraption
called a panoramic tripod head,
which gives me a precise way to capture
overlapping views of the scene on the
shooting and that's all I need.
With this compact setup,
I then capture multiple
views horizontally.
Let's call that x
multiple views vertically.
Let's call that y and multiple
exposures deep from dark to light.
Let's call that Z. It's not really depth.
It has nothing to do with distance.
It's it's about capturing a higher dynamic
range of exposures from underexposed,
overexposed to more closely match how
our IC instead of how the camera sees on
average, it takes me about a
minute to capture the entire scene.
I then use three different commercial
software packages to merge this cubic
array of photos into a coherent scene.
I blend them multiple exposures
from front to back with Aurora HDR.
I stitch together the multiple views
with auto panel pro and then I crop in
Sweden.
The image with Photoshop and what I mean
by Sweden is all I really do is adjust
the tonal range just a little
bit to take to reduce the haze.
Really now I'm calling these interim
results because you may have noticed I
haven't yet started talking about the
artificial intelligence element that I
introduced to my work, uh, last
year, but we'll do that in a minute.
With the technique of Xyz photography,
you end up with a scene that's more
immersive due to the wide angles,
both the x and the lie I've seen that's
more vivid due to the high dynamic
range,
the Z,
and I've seen that as much higher fidelity
containing up to 200 times as many
pixels as the HDTV and up to 10 to 40
times as many pixels as you'll get with a
pro DSLR camera.
What you're seeing here is a non retouched
photo of a four foot high by eight
foot wide light box that shows the kind
of detail and richness we're talking
about.
I put this graphic together to
illustrate the Xyz difference.
The the inset photo you see here on the
right is what you get with a high end
camera capturing a single exposure
with a 35 millimeter lens.
You can see that the Xyz method deals
an image that is much more immersive,
more vibrant,
and much higher resolution.
So finally we have to talk about
presentation to be most impactful.
These scenes should be printed,
in my opinion,
no less than eight feet wide
and they should be backlit.
We are creatures of light.
We're drawn to light. Um,
that's why I've been so
focused on producing light
boxes these last few years.
A big bonus about lightboxes is this,
their containers.
It's very easy to replace the
image, uh, to keep things fresh.
So it turns out the entire time I was
conducting my Xyz photography experiments,
there's been this incredible revolution
in artificial intelligence and deep
learning. Thanks perhaps to
some of the people in this room.
I'll let Joseph speak more
about this in depth after me,
but in July,
2015,
your company released a bit of open
source software called deep dream that
became a viral sensation. How many of you
were aware of that when that happened?
A few. Okay. So as I understand it,
deep dream was originally created to help
your researchers understand how their
own software was working.
And what they found when they applied
deep dream to image recognition was that
the machine was essentially hallucinating
as it was trying to figure out what it
was saying after they decided
to release the software.
The Internet went crazy
per these headlines.
What most people did with this was
they turn their family photos and to
psychedelic nightmares.
Now,
these are not my own,
but as you can see here,
some of these results were
quite intriguing. I, however,
since an opportunity to do
something a bit more subtle.
So I tried applying deep dream with a
light touch to some of my low resolution
previews of my landscape images.
The results were very well received,
but really excited me was this opportunity
to add a level of expressiveness to
my last scapes that could be very rich.
And just like the art world in the 18
hundreds began moving to more expressive,
individualized modes
of painting landscapes,
starting with the pronto impressionism
of JMW Turner and later the true
impressionism seen for example,
in the pointillism of Serah and the
unique styles of folks like Cezanne and
Monet. I thought I too
might be able to, you know,
take my landscapes in a new direction.
Unfortunately,
deep dream as released was simply not
designed to operate on multi hundred
megapixel images. It would just
crash and I was completely stuck.
So that's when I thought of my
friend at Google. Joseph Smart. Um,
and much to my delight and amazement,
Joseph actually agreed to help
me and he interned, coerced,
I mean convinced his friend Chris
Lamb, uh, and video to help him.
And this was a huge stroke of luck for me.
Cause when you think about the kind of
DNA you need to work on a project like
this, no pun intended, Chris and
Joseph were truly a dream team.
So it turns out it took a lot of work
to keep deep dream from crashing on my
images. Uh, when I'm done,
Joseph will share more details about
the challenges they faced and how they
overcame them. But after months
of hacking on nights and weekends,
by November,
2015,
they finally got it working using a
monster compute server with four graphics
processing units up on the Amazon cloud.
My job would then be learn how to tune
the parameters of deep dream for the best
results on my landscape images.
A couple of months after that,
in January, 2016, they
handed me this interface.
So let me explain this a little and
take you through my workflow first.
There's the fact that I have for GPS
graphics processing units at my disposal.
This means I can experiment very quickly
trying out four different dreaming
tests at a time,
at least on low resolution previous.
This allows me to rapidly converge on a
combination of parameter settings that I
feel is most compatible with my source
imagery. Speaking of parameters,
there's five that I get to fiddle with.
One main one and four sub parameters.
The main parameter is
the target layer name.
Deep Dream has released has 84 of these
layers and they tend to range from their
effect.
Every,
everyone has a different sort of dreaming
style and at the highest levels they
tend to be abstract slash impressionistic
where the algorithm is just starting
to look at lines and edges and at the
lowest levels it becomes more literal and
even animalistic because the AI is now
manipulating my image more deeply and its
quest to find the things that's been
trained to recognize things like animals
and objects and buildings.
Then there are four sub
parameters like number of octaves,
octave scale factor and so on,
which allowed me to fine
tune the intensity and scale
of the dreaming features.
So when I find it promising mix,
uh,
I commit to the full resolution version.
Uh,
and these typically take anywhere
from six to 20 hours of computing,
depending upon the size of the image.
The guys were kind enough to provide me
with this progress bar to keep track of
that. I try real hard not to press
that button there, cancel dream.
Um, but eventually I ended up with
uh, the full resolution thing.
Several hours later,
Chris lamb calculated that a typical 10
hour job probably performs about 150,
quadrillion floating point math
operations just to manipulate one image.
So it's working hard
usually while I'm sleeping.
So when we first started to get results,
I was delighted to see the following
happen. I suspect that it would,
but I wasn't totally sure this,
this thing I call the museum experience.
So have you guys noticed when you go like
to the met into the landscape painting
galleries that you walk in and on the
opposite wall you may see some large
sumptuous, almost photographic
landscape, but when you get close up,
you see all these brushstrokes and
expressiveness and perhaps some hidden
details,
right?
It's like having two different experiences
this far versus near dichotomy.
So besides the expressiveness,
that deep dream lent to my
work when I saw the results,
another thing that excited me was to
participate in another art tradition of
camouflage and dual meaning,
um,
such as you find in the works of art
and Boldo back in the renaissance who
painted portraits composed entirely
of fruits, vegetables, flowers,
et cetera. And in the late 18
hundreds and early 19 hundreds,
Abbott Thayer whose interest in protective
coloration in nature ultimately led
to the use of military camouflage and
World War One little side note about that.
And of course,
the Great Salvador Dali whose works
are filled with illusion and multiple
meetings.
So
this then brings us to
presenting dreamscapes with
this kind of detail in the
digital realm.
These images are essentially in prison.
Yes, you can zoom into them online,
but the more you zoom into the image,
the less of it you see.
This can be a very frustrating
experience and I can tell you,
and hopefully if you haven't already seen,
you will notice that
something fundamentally better
happens when you can walk
right up to a scene like this,
see all the crazy details and hold the
entirety of the image in your periphery.
That's one reason why I chose this large
format medium, and as I said earlier,
I'm all about back lighting.
And the last thing I should point out
is that the rich parameter space of deep
dream enables me to commit to
digital originals, meaning I never,
I can get away with never printing
the same exact image twice.
So another option for viewing dreamscapes
is with large video walls. Actually,
the first opportunity Joseph and I ever
had to see our dream scapes at scale was
down at the Qualcomm institute and Uc
San Diego on the vroom display as it's
called.
This was a really fun day,
especially after months of looking at
these images like with blinders on through
the limited window of a computer
monitor. Um, so it was thrilling. Um,
but I have to say even at 66 megapixels,
which is a lot for video,
a display,
this powerful could only deliver a
fraction of the pixels in our dreamscapes,
some of which are over 400 megapixels.
A lot of people ask me about viewing
dreamscapes in virtual reality.
I've had the good fortune of doing that
in a couple of different VR research
labs,
including yours.
And one thing that they all had to
solve was how to deliver the pixels
efficiently so that the system is
only displaying full resolution.
Depending upon where you're looking at,
how much you're zoomed in,
not hard to solve. It's been that that
problem has been solved for a long time.
It's basically is exactly
how Google Earth Vr works.
As you're navigating the planet, you
know, flying through the Swiss Alps,
you're really just flying through
a very large image dataset.
So personal. I'm very excited about,
uh, viewing dreamscapes and VR.
I've had the experience now in a number
of places and it's totally thrilling.
It's, it's, it's amazing
how immersive, uh, in fact,
just yesterday uptown,
I got to see this. Uh,
it's amazing how immersive this experience
is even though these images are only
two dimensional and,
and there's some great applications,
especially for this content given
the it's basis in healing art,
uh,
for things like Stress
Reduction and distraction
therapy for pain management and
things like that.
So just a quick stop observation I want
to make about all this and maybe about
technology in general, um, referring
to this sort of saw tooth curve here.
When you look at the different
technologies and methods for capturing and
conveying the power of a special place,
uh,
you'll find that each time
a paradigm shift occurs,
like the transition from landscape
painting to photography or from landscape
photography to Vr, there's a lot
of initial excitement and anxiety.
I mean, I, I think, think about it
and the, in the early 18 hundreds,
mid 1800 so when the landscape
painters were at the top of their game,
how do you think they felt when a device
comes along that can capture the actual
photons in the scene? Um, you know,
but the truth is it was a big
step down and quality and impact.
At first you couldn't make color,
you couldn't make huge prints,
the resolution wasn't there and so on,
but it's steadily improved.
And you had folks like Ansell
Adams producing majestic
black and white images in
the first half of the 20th century
and in the mid 19 hundreds,
Eliot porter who's intimate landscapes
did much to boost the acceptance of color
photography as an artistic medium.
Okay.
And in the late 20th century,
Peter Lik using panoramic
film cameras, um, you know,
to create works that at
least in some respects,
surpass those of the
representational landscape painters.
Okay.
So, well, I think a similar
thing is happening right
now. They're there, you know,
with the advent of virtual reality.
Again, a lot of excitement,
but a bit of a step down in quality and
impact with lots of room for improvement
and many problems to solve.
But that will happen.
And I for 1:00 AM not threatened by this.
I quite the opposite.
I'm excited to work with the our labs
and startups to help make that happen.
So back to dreamscapes just for fun,
I'd like to pause here and show you a
short video designed to illustrate the
variety,
the zooming power and the surprising
details within our dream scapes.
[inaudible]
all right.
So I'd like to end by coming back to my
original aspirations when I originally
set out to do and I hope I've been able
to achieve with the help of my ingenious
engineering collaborators, Joseph
Smart and Chris Lamb. And the,
of course tireless efforts of my new best
friend deep dream is to share with you
my experiences of special places.
I want it to project their power and
beauty through your eyes in such a way
that you feel it deeply in your body
and it engages your mind.
And as I reflect on this project and I
realized that by teaming up with an AI is
taking me beyond my initial ambitions
in that it's essentially unlocked a
superpower for me. I could never
execute these images solely on my own,
but it has required me giving up a degree
of control and that I can't tell it
exactly what to do.
And in fact,
I don't even fully understand how
or why it's doing what it's doing.
But as far as I know,
the AI has no innate desire to create
art nor any ability to discern which of
the parameter settings are most
aesthetically pleasing to humans.
I say as far as I know,
because Steve Jurvetson recently pointed
out that a sufficiently advanced AI
would choose to fail the Turing test.
Let's help Steve is wrong,
and that my AI is indeed just a tool.
I'll be at an incredibly
powerful tool, one that, uh,
might be somewhat beyond
our comprehension.
But ultimately I still make the decisions
as to how to steer it and what to keep
or discard.
I imagine the future of art,
science and technology will
be increasingly like this.
Where we use ais to process more data,
see more complicated patterns and
otherwise extend our natural capabilities,
but working towards goals
that we sat and direct.
I hope that my dream scapes project serves
as a clear example is that artificial
intelligence can enhance not only
our abilities and our productivity,
but even our creativity.
Thank you.
With that,
I'm going to introduce Joseph.
He's going to give a little talk
about the tech behind the art. Um,
and then we'll open it up to Q and
a with as much time as we have left.
Thanks a lot. Yeah, thanks
Dan. That was great. Um, yeah,
there's so much going on. Uh,
you know, he sort of roped me into
this a little while back and I thought,
how hard could this be? This will be fun.
You know, I'm, I'm a scrappy engineer.
Let's just see what we can
do. And then I was like, oh,
actually I have no what I'm doing.
Uh,
and so I share this because ultimately
obviously we were able to make it work.
And I think that's kind of an empowering
reminder that a lot of our sort of
basic skills as engineers in terms of
just trying things out and being willing
to iterate and asking for help and so
forth can get you surprisingly far. And I,
you know,
it's been surprisingly moving from me
to see how much has happened as a result
of this collaboration,
right?
This went way beyond just the fun
of problem solving and it's, uh,
it's made me kind of appreciate that I
don't have to just work on utility all
day,
that actually helping a expression as
it can be just as deeply moving in terms
of how we got there. So the, when
Dan sent me these low Rez thumbnails,
I forwarded them on the internal Google
plus and said, hey, aren't these cool?
You know, we were talking about scaling
them up. What are you think we need to do?
And, uh, some people, a bunch of
people inside the company, Solomon,
including some of the people on the
deep Dream Team and they said, yeah,
we've had some similar ideas.
You know,
you're going to have to do some sort
of a breaking it up into tiling.
Here's some original, some ideas to get
started and so forth. Um, and you know,
obviously you can't just take an entire
image, scale it down to the size,
you know,
the,
the actual networks work on image
is only a few hundred pixels wide.
So if you do that and dream it and scale
it back up, you lose all the details.
But if you just naively chopped the
image up into tiles and dream each child
separately, you get weird seems
between them. So you can't do that.
And so it turns out to work best is
to break the image down into tiles,
but instead of actually
chopping the image,
you just sort of slide a window around
the image and you, you know, in,
in the sort of the RGB matrix,
you,
you wrap the ends around so you can
kind of slide off the ends and you do a
random offset and jitter every time
you dream so that they don't line up
perfectly. And You keep doing
that for multiple iterations.
And you also sort of scale the image
up and down a bit as you're doing it.
And you can keep doing that for a while
because it's dreaming on its own output.
All the lines kind of disappeared and
it ends up being kind of one coherent
image.
And it also gives you these parameters
that Dan mentioned that I'll let you kind
of control the feature size and the,
and the intensity and also of course
the layer name and he's found kind of
different ways of applying
that for different images,
which was kind of a
surprising plus from that.
The other big challenge
is memory management.
And this again is sort of
took me by surprise because
there's sort of two layers
to it. One is the actual
dreaming all happens on the GPS.
And I should say,
by the way,
in apologies to my Google colleagues
that we did this on Amazon cause at the
time the GPU compute instances weren't
available on Google cloud. So that's a,
maybe we should, um, you know,
fix that now anyway. But, uh,
the GPU itself has memory on it and it's
only a fixed amount of memory and so
you can't overload the GPU with
too much pixels or it'll crash.
And so you have to kind
of size the workload.
And then a main memory actually turned
out to be a bigger bottle neck then GPU
memory for us,
which was surprising to me because
even at a few hundred megapixels,
these like the jpegs themselves are only
a few hundred megabytes. So I was like,
how hard can this be?
But I sort of forgotten.
It's obvious in retrospect that when
you're actually doing a dreaming or any
kind of neural network on an image,
you have to fully inflate
it so that you know,
each pixel is a 32 bit r n a g
and a B. Right? So it's sort of,
it's like an order of
magnitude or more memory. Um,
and then these python libraries that are
the sort of the standard ones for doing
scientific computing and,
and image manipulation and so forth,
they ended up making them kind of a lot
of like lazy array copies in the process,
which is normally fine, but when you're
input is several hundred megapixels, um,
it's not so fine.
And so a lot of the work ended up being
a kind of very careful memory profiling
and just sort of stepping through and
figuring out at each step what's going on
and trying to find clever ways to
avoid as many of these memory copies as
possible. Um, and you know,
thank God for open source,
right where a lot of these libraries
that we were using themselves were open
source. And so we could kind of go as
far under the hood as we needed to.
And eventually we actually got it
working. Um, and it's, you know,
what's cool too is,
I mean,
this was kind of a night and
weekend project is sort of,
could barely get it work.
And I'm,
you know how it is when you
first get your code running,
you're kind of scared to touch it because
you think you breathed on it wrong,
it's going to fall over.
Um,
but we handed it off to Dan and he spent
a week going crazy trying all these
experiments and it actually held up
pretty well. And so I guess, you know,
you don't have to set your bar at
something that is completely industrial
strength, right? Just be able to get
a tool that somebody can play with.
I think it's,
it's sort of surprising sometimes how
far you can take that and you know,
but it was python.
So we just put a very simple like Django
web Ui in front of it and we put all
the dreaming tasks behind a celery queue
so that you could get the progress bar
and you didn't have to wait 10
hours for your page to load,
but that was about it. Um, and then
the rest kind of took care of itself.
And you know, we've made a few little
tweaks along the way, but, uh, I,
I would just say it's, this is something
that I have got no formal training in.
Um, but it was a really exciting thing
to do and I'm sure you might find other
opportunities to do things
like that in the future.
Maybe not with deep dreaming per se,
but things like that.
So I definitely encourage you
to do that. Um, let's see.
Other things that are worth talking about.
I guess maybe let me just give you a
quick, for those of you haven't seen it,
a little explanation because people often
ask about why deep dream creates these
hallucinations in the first place.
And then we'll,
I'll bring back then up for
the rest of the Q and a.
So remember that what the way these
networks work is you feed an image in,
and this is like Google
photos or Google Lens.
One of these things you're trying
to figure out, is there a dog in it?
Is there a building in it? What have
you? And so the way it works is the,
the pixels come in at the bottom and
then you have a series of layers in the
neural network.
And each layer is trying to basically
learn statistical patterns of the output
of the previous layer. The first layer
starts to look for patterns of Pixels,
which might be a little like lines
or blocks of color or shapes.
And then the next layer we'll look for
patterns of those patterns and so forth,
right?
And so you get higher and higher level
concepts all the way up to eyes and faces
and so forth at the top.
And of course in the middle,
all of these layers that you've trained,
you've given lots of images where
you've told it what's in there. Um,
they've just learned these weight matrices
and that have optimized the target
function, but it's completely
opaque to you as a, as an engineer,
you have no idea why it did what it did.
And so when it gets something wrong,
you want to figure out, well, like why
did it misclassify this image? Um, you,
you sort of don't know what to change.
And so the deep Dream Team,
what they were trying to do was gain some
intuition for what these intermediate
layers had actually learned.
And so they have this very simple but
very clever idea for how to do it,
which is you run forward propagation in
the network up to the some middle layer
that you choose so that it's not,
it hasn't fully recognize the object but
it has some sort of patterns learned.
And then you say,
well how could I instead of normally know
when you're training a neural network,
you say,
how can I change the weights to do a
little bit better at recognize the image
here you do the exact opposite.
You say,
how can I change the image a little bit
to have the weights have done a better
job of recognizing whatever
it was recognizing.
Because remember that the image too is
just a ends up being just a matrix of
floats and so you can
essentially do gradient space,
gradient descent in Pixel space with
respect to the weights as opposed to
normally where you do gradient descent in,
you know,
wait space with respect to the pixels.
And that's all it does.
And then you just read that image
back out. And so it's kind of like,
I think about it like if you're staring
at a cloud and you sort of like see like
it looks like a horse or something.
And if you'd like to
think really hard to keep,
like make it look leaving a
little bit more like a horse,
that's essentially what you're doing.
Um,
and then what popped out
where all of these surprising
details. Um, and you know,
so that's why you see this,
you know,
this is the normal inception network
that we use in Google photos.
So it sees dogs and faces and buildings
and the things that we trained to
recognize. But you can train a network
on a different set of images and it would
hallucinate totally different
things in the image. And of course,
depending on the layer, it hallucinates
more or less than distract things. Um,
and they actually did find under,
if you've seen any of this,
they found some cool things in
the process. Um, like I guess the,
whenever they were trying
to learn a hammer, uh,
the image that came out of
the hallucination always
had an arm attached to it
and they had to go back and realize
it and all their training data,
they never gave it a picture of just
like a hammer lying on the table.
And so the image had, you
know, had always learned it.
So it's things like that you
wouldn't have otherwise realized.
And it actually ended up helping
with some of the training weights,
but it had this sort of
totally unexpected side effect.
And for those of you who are
around, you'll remember that. Um,
there was some posts on I think
internal gps as well of uh, the,
the deep dream team being like, here's
some weird images that have, uh, um,
you know, that, that we got
as a side effect of doing
this, this diagnostic work.
And of course Google is being Googlers
and all the source code being opened
internally,
they like grabbed it and started doing
it on their family photos and you know,
it sort of went viral internally and
that then prompted them to make an open
source version that led to all those
lovely pictures of the Dan showed you of
the Internet going crazy with deep dream.
Um,
so it's just kind of an
amazing progression, right? Uh,
to go from something that was really just
a tool scratching an itch to something
that's had this kind of
transformational power.
So I just wanted to share that anecdote
because I think there's gonna be lots
more opportunities for us all to do things
like that. Um, let me stop right there.
We still have about 10
minutes for questions. Uh,
come to the mic if you've got one so we
can capture it for the video and then
please feel free to stick
around afterwards for the
reception and we can chat
more.
So thanks very much guys.
Thank you.
Questions?
Who's got one?
I know you haven't physically
get it also clears yet.
Microphone closer to the mic please.
All right.
Well I love the fact that you gave that
whole art history progression because it
fits so well into their thank you.
And I particularly like the way,
if you look at like say saison and Monet,
the way that the artists take the
brushstrokes and manipulate them.
So even though they're not very realistic,
they really convey a different emotion
than you would if you had something very
realistic.
So I love that.
But the other question I had was
about the images once you or the,
the Ai images in the,
in the photographs,
did you pick and choose like multiple,
um,
you got different results? Did you
kind of incorporate something that was
like more important to you in
emotionally then than other images?
And how many times do you have to run
through that and what's cause that's
totally different than what artists
have done. So I found that really Greg,
great question.
So for sure given 84 different layers,
I want to have some ideas
of what I want to do,
at least in terms of do I
want this image to be cooked,
raw, medium or well
done? Meaning, you know,
sort of more abstract or more animalistic.
I tend to prefer the more impressionistic,
but there are times where it makes
sense to do it very animalistic,
like the wooded scene that has
all the creatures in it. You know,
the woods we know are alive,
but you walk through a peaceful grove
and Ma might hear a few birds chirping.
But other than that,
it seems really still.
But we intellectually know that there
are thousands of species all around us
that we just don't see. So in that case,
it really made sense to go that way.
Now there's a whole bunch of layers that
create different sort of animalistic
effects and to some people,
all of those are a little bit creepy,
but some are really creepy. And so, yeah,
I have to experiment. Conversely,
on the impression aside, um,
I had a canyon seen that,
um,
got printed for a couple of art fairs
in Miami and, uh, down in Florida.
And I really wanted to find a look as
if the native Americans had carved every
square inch of the canyon with
sort of a petroglyph kind of look.
And I found one,
it took some experimentation.
So typically when I say I'm
doing four at a time, um,
experiments on low rez previous,
I'll do like six of those sets,
all ended up doing like two dozen
attempts now because I'm working on a low
resolution previews, it hints at what
the final thing is going to look like.
It's not a guarantee that I will
have picked the right one. Um,
I would say I've gotten good enough at
it now so that when I finally do commit
to the large resolution job and I do pay
for time on the computer by the minute,
by the hour and minute, whatever.
Um, so I don't want to, you know,
I gotta be kind of judicious
about that to some degree,
but I usually end up getting what I
want on the first shot by that point.
But not always.
Sometimes I have to do the full resolution
of few times to get what I really
want. But especially when it comes to the
intensity and the scale of the feature,
sometimes I've got to
really tweak with that.
I was just thinking that, you know, I,
I did the simplest possible thing
of expose all the parameters and Ui.
That's like when you know, you know, you
don't really understand your user needs,
you just sort of give
them all the controls.
And normally that's not a good
idea as an engineer, right?
If you're building a
really usable product.
But it allowed Dan to do a lot more
matching of the style to the picture,
then I would have originally thought
possible. And one that I love is, uh,
he also got commissioned to build a piece
for a startup in Guadalajara, Mexico.
And so while we were there,
we went to,
there's this amazing old cathedral and
the senator of Guadalajara and he took
this interior, I think maybe we should
have one of the videos. And he did this,
he did this dreaming style,
which it's kind of like spirally and
it looks like you're having a religious
experience and they're so like for me
that like perfectly works with, you know,
yeah.
Subject.
That was a good example because we really
want to be careful not to do anything
that would be offensive to religious
people and conversely hoped to find
something that they would even be inspired
by and felt spiritual or a theorial.
Right. And we found, I think
we found something. Uh, it
took a lot of tries though.
You amazing thing is we were able to
do all of that to completion from our
Western hotel and Guadalajara.
That's right.
Because the robot is up in the cloud and
I could access it within that with any
Internet connection. Yay. Robot
overlords. More questions? We've got a,
we've got five minutes left on
five minutes. Any other questions,
Dan? You wouldn't, you
wouldn't. Joe One's an engineer,
one's a little bit further out than an
engineering and Joe Mixes Joe Mixes or
build something and it comes
up structurally this way.
You're a chemist from
what I'm seeing in your,
you're mixing it together and you're not
sure what happens and what I started up,
you're getting an idea
now when it's coming out.
What's the future you see for these?
You had mentioned something where you
wanted to use it for therapy and what some
of the future you say.
Yeah, so I think there's a couple
parts to that question. Um,
one is where kind of the
workflow goes from here,
where kind of where I can take it next.
And then there's the question
of of how can it be applied.
So in terms of what I'm doing
with it now as an artist,
in terms of trying to push
it is I continue to go on
photo expeditions and look
for special places and capture them and
ideally create full scene dreamscapes.
But in the last year working with a
number of art galleries and some really
astute gallerists and curators.
I've gotten some ideas for really
sort of taken this to a place.
At first I had never even thought of.
In fact when I heard the idea I objected
and realize later that this one curator
was right. Probably helps it. She's Phd
from the Sorbonne and everything else,
but she gave me this idea, she
said, what about what if you took,
you know if this is eight feet high,
what if you took a one foot square
detail right and blew that up to 40 by 40
inches and maybe dreamed on it afresh
with more intensity, what would you get?
It might be a really cool midsize piece
and I gave her all sorts of reasons why
it wasn't possible and that's not what
I do and all this turned out to be the
best thing I ever did it.
I just last week released a new series
called mining nightfall where I took that
central park twilight scene. You might
have noticed in the video and crew and,
and minded for like I ended up with 11
of those scenes and it's a wonderful
fanatic kind of set a,
so that's like where I'm sure there are
more ideas like that that others can
suggest or I can come up with over
time. In terms of the application, um,
again, this does have its
basis in healing. Art,
uh, is not what I initially set out
to do. What I set out to do was to,
I want it to get that
feeling across that I have.
And that feeling happens to be one of
the reason we love to go hiking and going
into nature and stuff like that is
because it makes us feel so good.
That's why they call them restorative
places. It restores us. Um,
and uh, so the application
I'm most excited about is,
is this sort of VR virtual reality
application for stress reduction.
And Like I said,
a distraction therapy for pain management.
Think of burn victims with
this opiate opiate epidemic.
You don't want to be handing out a
lot more painkillers then you need.
And it's known that the brain can only
process so much stuff and if you're
distracted doing something else,
you're not going to feel the pain as much.
So they've actually had good results
experimenting with burn victims,
putting them in a Vr headset and giving
them something really intense to focus
their concentration on and the need
for opiate drugs and painkillers is,
is significantly reduced now in
addition to making it something cool and
interactive, if you also make it something
that's got its basis in healing, art,
you know,
is this is going to be a win win.
And I think more broadly,
the WHO,
there's this idea of collaborating
with AI and having it extend your
capabilities,
but also as sort of a metaphor for the
future of knowledge work where we don't
necessarily have our hands completely
on the controls and we have to kind of
learn how to steer it and work
with it and accept its limitations,
but also let us go further
than we've been before.
And how it helps us think
about the way we see reality.
And I think there's just in,
in music and in video and imagery,
there's so much more opportunity there.
So this definitely convinced me that
we're just scratching the surface.
So we were told to wrap up at four o'clock
in four seconds. We're done. Thank you.
Very.
Thank you very much.